this is sarah with registerednessrn.com
and in this video i'm going to be
performing a nursing head-to-toe
assessment this video will be similar to
what you have performed
in nursing school whenever you're doing
your clinical check-off
now whenever you actually start working
as a nurse you'll be able to
tailor this head to toe assessment to
focus on the patient's
needs and you'll get a lot faster at
this
so what i want to do is i want to cover
literally how to assess
from the hair on the head all the way
down to
the toes so let's get started now when
you're doing your head to toe assessment
you
follow that sequence of how you assess
each system
so you start out whenever you're looking
at a system you're going to inspect it
then palpate percuss and then auscultate
except you're going to change it up a
little bit whenever you're going over
the abdomen you're going to inspect
auscultate
percuss and then palpate and the reason
that you're going to auscultate second
instead of last
is because whenever you perform
palpation percussion
if you did that before it could alter
the bowel sound so we want to go ahead
and just auscultate get a baseline of
what we can hear
and then we will percuss and palpate so
first what you want to do is you want to
perform hand hygiene
and provide privacy to the patient then
introduce yourself to the patient
and explain what you're going to be
doing so hello my name is sarah
and i'm going to be your nurse today and
i need to perform a head-to-toe
assessment is that okay with you
okay then proceed and look at their
armbands so
while you're doing this this is going to
help you make sure you have the right
patient
and you're going to be testing them to
see if they know who they are
their date of birth and ask them some
other questions to assess that
neurostatus
so say your first and last name for me
first name is ben last name is dover
okay and your date of birth 8 28 82.
okay and do you want me to call you ben
or mr dover what do you mean
okay so ben can you tell me where you're
at
i'm at the hospital okay and can you
tell me what we're doing here today
uh head to toe assessment okay and who's
the president of the united states
donald trump okay so he answered all
those correctly
and he's alert and he's oriented times
four he knew who he was he was able to
tell me his name
his date of birth where he was what
we're doing and current events so we can
chart
alert and oriented times four then you
want to collect vital signs such as the
patient's heart
rate blood pressure
temperature oxygen saturation
respiratory rate and the patient's pain
rating so ben are you having any pain on
a scale
zero to ten with zero being no pain at
all and ten being the worst pain you've
ever had
no pain zero okay and i have a video on
how to assess those vital signs in depth
if you want to watch that video
and a card should be popping up so you
can access that video
then after that what you want to do you
can collect their height
and their weight and look at the bmi
their body mass index remember if it's
18.5 or less that's underweight
or if it's greater than 30 that is obese
now while you've been doing all that
asking them these questions doing their
vital signs you're also before you've
even really assessed the
system you are already collecting
information
for instance how is that patient
responding to you what's their emotional
status
are they calm are they agitated are they
drowsy what's going on with them
do they look their stated age does his
skin color
match his ethnicity is he
does he understand my questions or does
he seem like he can't hear them very
well
or is there a delay whenever he responds
to me or does he respond
appropriately and at an appropriate time
also do you notice any just outward
abnormalities like an amputation any
masses
lesions is his skin sweaty cold and
clammy do you notice any cyanosis
right off the bat also do is his hygiene
good and is his posture good and do you
notice any abnormal
smell so during all that you're really
collecting all that
information now what we're going to do
is we're going to start with the head
and move our way down to the toes
so we are first going to inspect the
head
and we are looking at the skin color he
it's nice and pink we're also going to
make sure
that the head is the same size as how it
should be for the body
and it is and we're looking for any
abnormal
movements or twitching of the face that
he can't control that are involuntary
and we don't see anything
and we're making sure that the face is
symmetrical there's no drooping on one
side like in this picture
there's drooping on one side of the face
and this can be seen in bell's palsy
or in stroke and we're also just looking
at the eyes and the ears
are they at the same level and while
we're here we're going to go ahead
and look at the facial expressions and
test cranial nerve 7 which is the facial
nerve so can you close your eyes tightly
for me and open them up
okay now smile for me frown
and puff out your cheeks okay and he did
that with ease so that cranial nerve is
intact next what we're going to do is
we're going to palpate
the head the cranium we're going to
check for any masses indentations look
for skin breakdown any infestations and
for this part
i like to wear gloves so let's look at
the hair
so what we're doing is we're filling for
any masses indentations and also with
this we're looking for any skin
breakdown and if your patient's immobile
you really want to check the back of the
head back here
because they're laying on it a lot and
there can be breakdown back there
also while you're doing that look inside
the hair make sure there is no
infestations like lice and there's no
abrupt like rounding areas of baldness
which could represent
alopecia then after that since this
patient has
a beard you want to check the beard as
well
any lesions any infestations or anything
like that and just look around
and then once you're done with that what
you want to do is you'll doff your
gloves and perform hand hygiene
next what we're going to do is we're
going to find the temporal artery and
we're going to palpate them bilaterally
and they are both
found right here and that his
are about a two plus and then while
we're right there we're going to go
ahead and test
cranial nerve five which is the
trigeminal nerve and this nerve is
responsible for many things like
mastication so what i'm gonna have you
do then is i'm gonna have you clench
your teeth like bite down
for me and i'm going to fill them with
cedar muscle which is right there that
should be a nice firm ball
and then feel the temporal muscle
now what i'm going to do to also test
that nerve is have him try to open his
mouth against resistance so try to do
that for me
okay and he can do that now
while we're here we're going to go ahead
and feel the temporal mandibular
joint and we're going to feel right here
and i'm going to have you open and close
your mouth
and i'm feeling for any grading or
clicking sensations and i feel
none then we're going to palpate the
sinuses
and i'm going to put pressure on these
two sinuses right here and you tell me
if you feel any pain okay
so the max max maxillary
and the frontal no next we're moving
down to the eyes and we're going to
inspect the eyes first and we're looking
at several things we're looking at the
eyelid
we're looking at the sclera which is the
white of the eyes we're looking at the
iris we're looking at the pupil
and we're looking at the conjunctiva so
you shouldn't see any swelling of the
eyelids you should
see that the sclera is white and
shiny it shouldn't be yellow like in
jaundice
and the conjunctiva when you pull down
the lower lid have the patient look up
it should be
nice and pink it shouldn't be red you
shouldn't see any drainage or anything
like that
and look at the eyes how do they set in
the eye socket
is are they equal for instance says is
there any strabismus
is there a cross eye where one eye turns
in more turns out or up or down
and these eyes are normal there's no
strabismus
next you want to look at antisequoria
where you
have where one pupil would be smaller
than the other people are they equal in
size
normal pupils should be three to five
millimeters
in their measurement and here his
are about a three and they are equal
next what we're going to do is we're
going to assess some cranial nerves
we're going to be looking at cranial
nerve
three which is ocular motor four
trochular and then
six which is abducens and we're gonna do
several tests to
check their function the first one what
we're gonna do is we're gonna be looking
for any involuntary shaking of the eye
called nystagmus and how we're going to
do that is we're going to take our pen
light
we're going to hold it about 12 to 14
inches away from the patient's nose
and then what i want you to do is keep
your head still don't move your head
and just use your eyes to watch where i
move the pin line
and as you're doing this you're going to
do you're going to perform it in the six
cardinal fields of gaze and you're just
going to move it and you're looking for
any involuntary shaking of the eyes so
here we go
next we're going to see how reactive the
pupils are to
lie and to do that we're going to dim
the lights a little bit and we're going
to have the patient
stare off at a distant object that helps
dilate those
pupils and then we're going to shine
using our pin light in at the side
and we're going to see how that pupil
responds it should constrict and then on
the other side it should constrict as
well
so say their baseline people size was
like three millimeters it should go down
to one milliliter and it should happen
on both sides
okay so ben stare off at that object
right on the wall over there for me
okay and that dilates the pupils and
we're just gonna shine
light in at this side okay
constrict constrict okay
then dilate again then go back to the
other side do the same again
and they both constricted in equal size
next what we're going to do is we're
going to check for accommodation
and how we do that is we turn the lights
back on we just previously had them dim
but we now make it light again
we're going to have him stare off at a
distant object that helps dilate the
pupils
and we're going to take a pen light you
can use a pin light finger and you're
just going to slowly
move it inward to the nose and what
you're looking for is that those pupils
constrict they accommodate and the eyes
cross while looking at the pen line so
here we go stare off in the distance
please and i don't want you to move your
head or anything just keep it real still
and just follow this pin light okay
ready
okay so now we can document because we
just checked
all of the things with the eyes we can
document that the pupils
are equal round reactive to lie and
accommodate so that's where
that acronym p-e-r-r-l-a
comes into play next we're gonna move on
to the ears so first what we do is we
inspect the ears
we look on the outside of the ear is
there any abnormalities
any redness any drainage anything like
that
and ben are you having any pain in your
ear okay
and sometimes if you have patients
who've had
long-term gout on the helix of the ear
they may have what's called a
tophi which is an accumulation of like a
whitish
yellowish uric acid crystal on the skin
so if you ever see that
that is what that looks like next we're
going to palpate on the ear
we're just going to move it around and
bend tell me if you have any tenderness
whenever i do that
and any feel any abnormal masses or
lesions and then move the targets a
little bit does that hurt or anything
like that
okay so no pain or tenderness then we're
going to palpate
the mastoid process which is the big
hump behind the ear
and we're looking at it is it swollen is
there any redness and whenever i touch
on it then does it hurt
okay and just see if the patient reports
any tenderness with that
then while you're there you can use the
otoscope to inspect the tympanic
membrane and remember the tympanic
membrane should be a pearly gray
translucent
color and should be shiny so for an
adult you're going to
pull the pin out of the ear up and back
and we're just going to inspect it
and also while we're looking at that
we're looking at the cone of light and
remember the cone of light in the right
ear should be at five o'clock
and then the left ear should be at seven
o'clock next we're gonna do one more
thing with the ear we're gonna test
cranial nerve eight which is the
vestibulo
cochlear nerve and what i'm going to do
is i'm going to include
one of his ears and then whisper two
words on the other side he needs to tell
me
what i said so you ready okay i'm gonna
include this one
apple banana okay very good
dog cat dog okay
and that nerve is intact next we're
going to move on to
the nose and we're going to inspect the
nose we're going to make sure it's
midline on the face which it
is we're going to look at the septum is
it deviated anything like that
and ask the patient or you have any
trouble with your nose are you having
any drainage or anything like that
no and you want them to make you want to
check the patency of the nose so then
i'm going to have you occlude one side
the nostril breathe out the other
and vice versa okay
heard airflow airflow nice and patent
because sometimes people can have polyps
that can block it or the deviated septum
then you want to take your pen light and
you just want to look inside the nose
look for any drainage redness or any
like polyps or anything
like that and everything looks clear i
don't see anything
and then we're going to test the olaf
factory cranial nerve
one the sense of smell so ben what i'm
going to have you do
is i'm going to have you close your eyes
and i want to put something
in front of your nose and have you
breathe in and smell and you tell me
what you smell
and whenever you do this use something
that's pleasant smelling not something
that's really stinky
because it could elicit like a gag
reflex or something like that if the
person has a sensitive nose
okay vanilla
okay and this was vanilla extract and
that's correct
so that cranial nerve is intact next
we're going to move on
to the mouth and for this part like to
wear gloves and if your patient is
coughing and hacking you might want to
wear a mask with a shield
so you don't get any mucus on your face
or in your mucous membrane so first what
we're going to do we're just inspecting
the lips make sure they're nice pink
color they're not
chapped there's no sores on them
and one thing with a lot of patients
whenever their oxygen saturations are
low their lips may turn
dusky or blue color so you want to make
sure they're nice and pink because that
can represent our oxygen level
now let's inspect the inside of the
mouth but first let's test cranial nerve
12 which is the hypoglossal
nerve and what i'm going to have you do
then is i'm going to have you stick out
your tongue and move it side to side
okay and he does that with ease now what
we're gonna do is we're going to
inspect the inside of the mouth you'll
need a tongue blade for that
and just open up your mouth for me and
i'm gonna look on the inside of the
cheeks
nice and pink don't see any sores you're
looking to see if they're nice and pink
and
there's no lesions or anything like that
and stick out your tongue for me the
tongue should be
moist like this and pink you don't want
it to be
beefy red which is like in pernicious
anemia you don't want it to be dry
or cracked that could be dehydration cut
you can put the tongue in then i want
you to lift up your tongue for me
and look for any lesions underneath the
tongue that's where mouth cancer can
hang out and i don't see any okay you
can close
then you'll while you're also looking at
the gums open up a little bit
you're going to look around for cavities
any loose or broken
teeth no dental caries in there
then okay sort of open up your mouth a
little bit more put your tongue down
and you're going to look at the soft and
hard palate
now while you're in there you want to
look at the uvula make sure it is
nice and midline and his is nice and
midline and we're going to
test cranial nerve 9 the
glossopharyngeal so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to have you say ah and what
you want is that uvula
to move up okay
and then we're just going to test the
gag reflex i'm sort of just going to
poke a little bit back there and
elicit a gag reply okay there you go
kag's really good and cranial nerve 10
the vegas is intact because he's able to
talk with talk to me without hoarseness
and he's
able to swallow then when you're done
inspecting the mouth be sure you take
off your gloves and perform
hand hygiene now moving on to the neck
so what we're going to do is we're going
to inspect the neck
first so you're going to have the
patient extend the neck up a little bit
and you're looking at that trachea is it
midline
look for any lesions and look for any
lumps like what you might see in thyroid
problems like
a gourder and we don't see any of
that then what we're going to do is
we're going to test cranial nerve 11
which is the accessory nerve
so again what i'm going to have you do
is move your head side to side
up and down okay and then
shrug try to shrug against my resistance
and he does
that with ease so that nerve is intact
then we're going to place him at a 45
degree
angle and we're going to have him turn
his head to the side and what we're
looking at
is the jugular vein we're looking for
any jugular vein distension jvd
so again i'm going to just turn your
head to the side like that and we're
looking for any distinction of the vein
and we do not
see any next what we're going to do is
we're going to palpate so we're going to
palpate that trachea just to confirm it
is midline
and ben do you feel any tenderness or
anything like that ask him if he feels
any tenderness
and i don't feel any lumps the next what
we're going to do
is we're going to palpate the lymph
nodes
all sights of those and as i do this
tell me if you feel any tenderness
and what i'm feeling for is any hard
lumps or anything that may be in flame
so
what we're going to do turn a little bit
this way
and there we go we're going to start at
the pre-auricular which is right in
front of the ears
then we're going to go to the back of
the ears the post auricular
then we're going to go to the occipital
the parotid
jugular digastric
then we're going to go to the
submandibular
and then the submental
then we're going to go to the
superficial cervical
and then we're going to make our way
down to the
deep cervical chain any tenderness so
far
then we're going to go to the posterior
cervical and then right above the
clavicle we're going to go to the
supraclavicular
and did not feel anything and no
tenderness next we're going to palpate
the carotid artery
and this is one artery that you do not
palpate bilaterally you do
one individually so we're going to feel
on this side
and you're going to find it next to
where the
groove of the neck and next to the
trachea and his
is nice and bounding it's two plus
then we're just gonna fill on the other
side
and same strength two plus
and lastly what we wanna do is we're
gonna auscultate the
carotid artery and you're gonna do one
side at a time
and you're gonna compare sides and
you're going to listen with the
bell of your stethoscope and we're
listening for a brewery which is a
swishing sound
so ben what i'm going to do is i'm going
to have you breathe in breathe out and
hold it for me okay go breathe and
breathe out
okay you can breathe normally now
did not hear it on that side okay
breathe in breathe out
for me and hold it
okay and i did not hear a brewery on
that side as well
now let's move to the upper extremities
so what we're going to do is we're going
to inspect the
extremities and we're looking for any
lesions any redness swelling
and this is a good time if they have a
central line an iv
that you look at that make sure it's not
red does iv need to be changed does that
picc line or
central line need a dressing change
assess that
then you can palpate and what we're
going to do is we're going to palpate
our pulse our radial artery
so fill those bilaterally and they are
two
plus and they're equal then we're going
to check capillary
refill and to do that we're just going
to press down on that nail bed
and see how fast it comes back and it's
less than two seconds then we're going
to check skin target
by just pinching the skin and see how
fast it goes back and that was good
then we're just going to look at the
range of the motion of the fingers and
the hands
look at these joints in the hands do you
see anything abnormal
like for instance like herbedine or
beauchard's nodes which
are found in osteoarthritis and
acetation are you having any pain in
your hands or anything like that
no then you can palpate the brachial
artery which is found in the bends of
the arm
and just fill those because that's
another pulse site and those are two
plus
and just as a side note if this was a
patient that was getting
dialysis and they had an av fistula you
would want to palpate that and feel for
the thrill make sure that that is
present up in that arm wherever their
fistula is at
then you want to test the muscle
strength
so what we're going to do is i'm going
to have you squeeze
my fingers as hard as you can okay
okay that's really good then i'm going
to have you push
up against my hands and i'm going to
push up against your
arms okay push okay very good
okay and five plus normal strength
then we're just going to test his put
your hand underneath the elbow and just
feel as you move the arm do you feel any
grading crepitus of those joints a lot
of times in arthritis
you can feel that and move that
bilaterally
another thing you want to do with the
upper extremities is to check for a
drift
and what you will do is you'll have the
patient hold out their arms and close
their eyes hold it up for about 10
seconds
and you're looking for a drift like this
so go ahead
do that and close your eyes okay and
we're assessing to see if this hand will
drift upward and a lot of times
if a patient has had a stroke okay you
can put them down has had a stroke or
something like that
you will see a drift next we're moving
on to the chest
and we're going to inspect the chest
we're looking for
any abnormalities like lesions
or any wounds anything like that we're
also
inspecting the patient's effort of
breathing is it really labored are they
using those accessory muscles to breathe
also we're looking at that anterior
posterior
diameter so turn to the side like that
and you're looking for that barrel chest
and it will be increased in patients
with like
copd they will have what's called the
barrel chest
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to listen
to heart sounds and then we're going to
listen to lung sounds so first let's
auscultate
heart sounds and we're going to do this
in five locations
and they're based on where the valves
are located and i like to remember the
mnemonic
all patients effectively take medicine
and the first letter of each word
represents the valve except for
effectively so a would be aortic
p in patients would be pulmonic
effectively would be herb's point and
this is just the halfway point between
the base of the heart and the apex of
the heart and there's no valve location
there and then t
is for tricuspid and then m is for
medicine
so again using the diaphragm we're going
to listen
at the right of the sternal border at
the second intercostal space and that's
going to be the aortic
valve so to find that second intercostal
space find the sternal notch
go down to the angle of lewis then just
go a little bit to the right and you're
in the second
intercostal space and this will be the
aortic
and we're just listening lub dub lub dub
s1
s2 and s2 the dub is going to be louder
in this location then we're going to go
a little bit over
to where the pulmonic valve is found
that's on the left of the sternal border
at the second intercostal space so we're
just right across
again just listening to lub dub lub dub
and s2
dub is going to be louder in this
location then we're going to go a little
bit down to the third intercostal space
and this is herb's point and again
you can hear lub dub but there's no
specific valve
here then we're going to go down to the
fourth intercostal space
and this is where the tricuspid valve is
and lub s1 is going to be the loudest at
this location
then we're going to go to the fifth
intercostal space
mid clavicular line and we're going to
listen to
the mitral valve and again
s1 is going to be loudest here dub and
there's something special about this
site this is the point of maximal
impulse this is where you're going to
listen for the apical pulse so we're
going to set here we're going to count
it for one full minute
and a normal apical pulse in adult
should be 60 to 100 beats per minute
and his apical pulse was 63. then we're
going to switch
over with the bell of our stethoscope
and we're just going to repeat
in those locations and we're
specifically listening for heart murmurs
so that swishing
blowing sound so that's what we're going
to listen to with that
and i did not hear any now let's listen
to lung sounds now when you're listening
to lung sounds you're
listening for abnormal sounds and here
are some samples of some abnormal sounds
that you may hear
crackles
wheezes
a friction rub
or strider
first we're going to listen anteriorly
and what we're going to do is we're
going to listen with the diaphragm of
our stethoscope
and we're going to start at the apex of
the lungs and we're going to always
compare
sides and just enter way downward and
assess all the lobes of that right and
left
lung so first let's start up here okay
and then i want you to take
good deep breath in and out so here we
go apex
okay we're going to compare sides
then we're going to move down to the
second intercostal space
and this is going to help us assess the
right upper lobe and the left upper lobe
so another deep breath in and out
then we're going to go down to the
fourth intercostal space and we're going
to assess
where our right middle lobe is and our
left upper lobe because remember the
right
lung has three lobes and the left lung
has two lobes so
let's listen to our left upper lobe
we're just going to go down a little bit
more
then we're going to go mid axillary at
the sick six
intercostal space and we're going to
listen to the right and left
lower lobe so you just want to turn to
the side right there
until you get deep breath in for me
okay other side
okay now let's listen posteriorly again
using the diaphragm and the stethoscope
you're going to start listening at the
apex and work your way
down and one thing to keep in mind when
you're listening back here you have the
scapula
and you don't want to listen over those
because you won't be able to hear the
sound so you're going to listen
in between where the scapula and the
spine are so down in these
regions right here and again we're just
going to compare sides and
you can do this part at the end if you
wanted to whenever you turn your patient
over to look at their back side
but we're just going to go ahead and do
it now so we're going to start
in the apex
compare sides
then we're going to find c7 which is
that vertebral prominence it's the big
ball right there you can't miss it and
go down to about
t3 and you'll be in between the shoulder
blades
and go a little bit in between the
shoulder blades and the spine right in
there and you're going to
assess the right and left upper lobes
then from t3 to t10
we're just going to inch around and
we're going to listen to the right and
left
lower lobes
okay now we're going to assess the
abdomen and remember we're switching our
sequence and how we
assess we're going to do inspection
auscultation
and then percussion or palpation
so we're going to do auscultation second
so whenever you're looking and assessing
the abdomen have the patient lay
on their back and what we're going to do
is we're going to inspect the abdomen
and first i want to ask ben are you
having any stomach issues at all
no no okay and when was your last bowel
movement yesterday morning
yesterday morning and how are you
urinating do you have any pain why
you're peeing
do you have problems starting a stream
any discharge anything like that
no it fits longer okay and with your
male patients you want to ask about that
due to
prostate enlargement was starting a
stream and if he was female i would ask
him when his last menstrual period was
and also again asked the female patient
about urinating
and things like that now if the patient
had a foley this is the time when you
would want to look at the urine inspect
the foley
and look at that just conglomerate your
urinary system
and your gi system together okay so
we're inspecting the abdomen
we're looking at the abdominal contour
and this patience is scalphoid it goes
in a little bit you can also have
flat rounded or protuberant
and also we're going to know if there's
any pulsations
a lot of times in this area right here
on thin patients like with ben i can see
the aortic pulsation in this patient's
right above the umbilicus
and looking at the belly button and
checking for any masses do we see
any hernias or anything like that also
if your patient had any wounds you would
want to look at that
and if they had a peg tube you would
want to assess the site make sure it's
not red
and ask them how it feels and with
your ostomies with your awesomeness you
want to look at the stoma
and make sure it is like a rosy pink
color it's not a dusky cyanotic color
and it's not prolapse and look and see
what type of stool
it's putting out and note that note the
smell
note when if the bag needs to be changed
anything like that
so now we're ready to listen to the
bowel sounds
and what we're going to do is we're
going to listen
with the diaphragm of our stethoscope
and we're going to
start in the right lower quadrant and
work our way
clockwise and we're going to listen to
all four quadrants
and you should hear five to thirty
sounds per minute
and if you don't hear any bowel sounds
you need to listen for five
full minutes and you need to know are
these normal are they hyperactive
or hypoactive so let's listen
okay this is our right lower quadrant
we're going to move up to the right
upper quadrant
move over to the left upper quadrant
and then down to the left lower quadrant
and bowel sounds are normal now we're
going to listen for vascular sounds and
you're going to do this with the bell of
your stethoscope and we're going to
listen
at the aortic we're going to listen at
the renal arteries iliac arteries and
you could listen at the femoral artery
arteries if you needed to so you're
going to listen at the aorta artery and
it's a little bit below the xiphoid
process a little bit above the umbilicus
so about right here
and we're listening for like a blowing
swishing sound which would represent a
brewee
okay and none is noted then we're going
to listen at the right
and left renal arteries which is a
little bit down
from the aorta location so here's the
right
okay none note it and then over the left
then we're going to listen at the iliac
and it's a little bit below the belly
button
right here
and this is the iliac artery and then
listen on the other side
and again like i pointed out you could
listen at the femoral artery in the
groin if
you needed to now we're going to do
palpation first we're going to do
light palpation then deep and then as i
do this please tell me if you feel any
pain or tenderness
so first we're going to do light
palpation we'll just start in
the right lower quadrant work our way
around and you're going to go about two
centimeters and you're just feeling for
any
rigidity any lumps masses
anything like that how's that feel
it feels fine okay
okay now we're going to do deep
palpation
and we're going to go about four to five
centimeters so a lot
more deep and again you're just feeling
for any masses lumps and ben tell me if
you have any tenderness and sometimes
you can do this with two hands
if need be if you're not strong enough
like me
feeling anything feels nice and soft
heard some belly sounds that's why you
do this after you listen
because you stimulate it
okay everything felt good now we're
going to assess the lower extremities so
first what we're going to do is we're
going to inspect we're going to look at
the color from the legs
to the toes making sure it's nice and
pink and here
we see that ben has a little bit of a
tan line here and
we're looking at the hair growth as well
you want to make sure there's normal
hair
hair growth because in pvd you will see
hairless shiny thin
legs and here we have excellent hair
growth and
also do you see any abnormal swelling
just right off the bat before you've
even touched the patient
and look at the legs and the feet for
any swelling
redness swelling do you have any pain or
anything in your legs anything like that
and looking at the joints make sure
there's no redness on the joints because
a lot of times
with gout it likes to start out in the
big toe so make sure
that everything looks good and then on
your diabetic patients make sure you
look at the bottoms of their feet
because these patients
don't have the best feeling in their
feet so their shoes could be wearing on
them
or they could have stepped on something
and not even know it so inspect those
feet make sure there's no ulcers or
anything that like that that needs to be
addressed
also look at the toenails do the
toenails look healthy
or is there fungus are they missing
toenails they have a really bad ingrown
toenail
so assess for that next you want to
palpate your pulses
we'll palpate the popliteal pulses which
are behind the knee
and those are about two plus they're
equal bilaterally
i'm just filling his legs they're nice
and warm
and i'm going to push over his tibia
firmly
and i'm seeing if there's any edema so
push there and if there is edema a lot
of times whenever you push down it's
like this hard light type
gel it'll just separate and your finger
will leave this indention
and here we don't have any
now we're going to palpate on the feet
and we're going to fill on the pulses
and i'm going to don gloves perform hand
hygiene dawn gloves and we're going to
feel on the pulses and the feet
we're going to feel on the posterior
tibial
and 2 plus really good and then we're
going to fill the dorsalis pedis which
is
on top of the foot
two plus with that and if you can't ever
find these because sometimes these are
hard to find in patients
you can get a doppler if you have one on
your floor
next i'm going to check the capillary
refill on his
toes just like how we did with the
fingers by pushing down
in less than two seconds
check the other one
okay now i'm going to have him push
against my hands push against my hands
ben
okay good job now i'm going to have you
raise your
legs against resistance good job
now we're going to check the babinski
reflex and you can use your reflex
hammer for this and use the end of it
or you can use your finger if you don't
have that and what we're going to do is
we're going to
take this up through the ball of the
foot and curve it and we're looking for
the toes to curl in which would be a
negative normal response so let's check
that
okay okay
and that was normal then we're going to
dolph our gloves and perform hand
hygiene
and next we're going to assess the back
so whenever you're looking at the back
side you're going to look
from the head all the way down at the
back and
you really want to pay attention to any
abnormal moles
lesions wounds anything like that and
assessing for skin breakdown especially
on your patients who are mobile
so that would really be concentrating on
in
the backside area on the coccyx because
that's where
a lot of breakdown happens and on the
back of those
heels if you couldn't see it whenever
you were assessing the feet
and also you could if you hadn't already
you could listen to the lung sounds as
you have the patient
over on the back okay so that wraps up
the nursing head to toe assessment
now please be sure to check out my other
videos because i have a lot of
nclex review videos to help you study
for nclex along with other nursing skill
videos career tips and everything you
need
to succeed in nursing school all the way
to becoming
a nurse in your profession so thank you
so much for watching and please consider
subscribing to this youtube channel